es ist wirklich bedenklich der
klimawandel lasse ich in den letzten
wochen und monaten extrem beschleunigt
in der arktis steigen die temperaturen
auf werte mit dem absolut niemand
gerechnet hat in australien führt eine
hitzewelle zu strom ausfällt und in der
sahara schneit es was ist los mit
unserem planeten der überblick zum
fertig zum herzlich willkommen was jetzt
passiert doch verstehen nicht mal mehr
die experten so schnell hat sich in den
letzten wochen und monaten alles
geändert
die welt meteorologie organisation kurz
wie immer schlägt jetzt alarm zitat wir
sie in bemerkenswerte veränderungen rund
um den planeten welche an die grenzen
von unserem verständnis des klimawandels
gehen wir sind jetzt auch wirklich
unerforschtes gebiet was sagt david
kerstens direktor des weltklima
forschungsprogramms der wm
experten wissen nicht mehr weiter das
jetzt wirklich nicht mehr beruhigen was
karten da gesagt hat gerät die erde
jetzt aus den fugen was passiert im
moment in den vergangenen monaten gab es
drei regelrechte hitzewellen in der
arktis dreimal stiegen die temperaturen
sogar nachts clark auf null grad
normalerweise liegen sie im winter im
zweistelligen minusbereich die arktische
eisfläche war noch nie so klein sie
waren nur 14 4 quadratkilometer im
maximum groß das war die kleinste je
gemessene maximal schlecht eine so
beachtet hat folgen für das wetter
weltweit das offene meer heißt mit
seinen deutlich dunklen flächen im
gegensatz zum arktischen eis die luft
darüber auch von diesen riesigen flächen
verdunstet jetzt viel mehr wasser und
regnet und schneit über anderen regionen
wieder ab die bawag das wiederum
schwächt den polaren jetstream der fängt
dadurch an im wahrsten sinne des wortes
herum zu einer gebühren- sich beulen in
stream also die sogenannten roski werden
die werden deutlich verstärkt sie
bringen paradoxerweise jetzt kalte
polarluft mit viel schnee weiter in den
süden der bürger in den usa letzte woche
war dafür ein perfektes beispiel ein
wintersturm im märz auf dem breitengrad
von süditalien verrückt eine rock die
welle hat ihn verursacht und auch von
unten vom wasser brot und ist um gemacht
die ozeane werden immer wärmer in ihrer
obersten schicht die drei meter dicke
speichern die meere genau so viel
energie wie die gesamte erdatmosphäre
und die wird schneller viel wärmer laut
der aktuellen studie des forscherteams
um links schenk von der tennis academy
of sciences in peking werden die ozeane
ein schneller warm als bisher gedacht
992 war das tempo der erwerbung bereits
doppelt durch schnell die 960 und auch
fw 190 190 werden auch wasserschichten
anna tiefe von 700 metern wärmer und
eine studie aus dem januar die sich nur
mit den daten der meeresoberfläche
beschäftigt hat auch noch weitere
beunruhigende zutage geförderte
hausvater von der university of
california und sein team werden die
daten von bojen satelliten und
tauchrobotern aus ergebnis laut neuester
97 hat sich das wasser pro jahrzehnt und
0 12 grad aufgeheizt bisher dachten
experten dass werden 007 das
zwanzigfache
die klimaforscher haben sich also
tatsächlich gehört aber es ist anders
als die verschwörungstheoretiker glauben
der klimawandel fällt nicht aus sondern
er kommt schneller und wird schlimmer
in diesem sinne noch einen schönen
welttag der meteorologie schaut euch
unbedingt man diese zu den champions an
da gibt es noch mehr infos da drauf
klicken einfach und wenn ihr in zukunft
nicht verpassen wollen dann wird mir
hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht nur noch einen auf
die glocke zu geben tja und was bald
werden so am tag noch zu sagen
wir sind dran